probably what's that Tito what's up
Brandon GE Z's really hit rock bottom
disco king it do you sing it cuz I mean
I come out here at 8 o'clock in the
morning drink a couple tall boys smoke a
couple joints gang [ __ ] that sounds fun
Gang Gang buzz oh [ __ ] yeah
get that buzz disc get that buzz dis
buzz lightyear diff dog [ __ ] buzz
baldwin dude out there you get that karl
malone [ __ ] post up can you see that
Shaun disc-off have you played it I've
never played it that sounds fun as hell
though you can't go on the golf courses
right now though right and do they just
go on like regular golf course and
throat disk no there's like an actual
course for ya oh it's that big yeah I've
done it
man I know I'm gonna get more hip if you
go to in like Colorado they have like
really well groomed ones that have
actual greens and like lakes and stuff
it's it gets pretty serious this one's
from dude yeah I need to check it out
look at look at a map like oh yeah it's
wrong I've never played have you guys I
just made my first video the other day
you put on Instagram yeah bring that
[ __ ] up I'm not lying
did you have music claimed like all
those small things and [ __ ] do Ally
cuz I'm oblique 180 to fit oh okay trust
park is my boy let's see this can hear
it yep
Wow done that music is intense music huh
it's a bright fun to skate to though
right sounds like white supremacist
music no huh
are they is that not the track from
[ __ ] American History X oh you can
skate skate
oh damn son
that wasn't an ollie yeah yeah we did
it's exactly what we thought you're full
of [ __ ] back over that resume there's
some [ __ ] red flags in that now we
know it's so cool with black fishing
[Laughter]
yeah go back over that resume look at my
racism chart you're a liar [ __ ]
culture vulture and ever
save some for the rest the white kids to
Cheerilee yeah man when is it stop you
know he's only guitar
[Laughter]
I posted guitar video 9 man really
talking about God
[Music]